quand tu tiennes au cours de la
martinique
à mon avis je pense que ce sera plus ou
moins nuit ici pour la martinique parce
que on a une perte nette de shane bauer
qui sort du lot et je crois que c'est ça
notre encouragement nous les anciens
alfredo fonteece le président du comité
de massif piste de mort d'amy et tous
les clubs
enfin pas tous les clubs penser à des
exceptions quand même mais je crois
savoir avec ces jeunes qu'on a vu ali
ben là nous aurions des huées des
résultats vraiment positif au 58e tous
ces pistes et vous en tant qu ancien
coureur est ce que ça vous rappelle
l'épisode de 1965 où vous avez gagné le
tour de la martinique
eh bien il faut dire que ça n'a rien à
voir ce qu'il ya dans une course à
étapes et à la gestion et à
l'intelligence pas soit plus sûr encore
un coup ou gagné une course avec la tête
mais pas forcément avec les jamais on se
sait tout de martinique 1065 que je
gagne je les gagne à l'avant pour mieux
et à plus ou moins le premier jour où je
gagne l'étape du matin avec cinq minutes
si l'étape de l'après midi avec quatre
minutes qui me faisait neuf minutes et
j'ai pu gérer ça jusqu'à l'arrivée et à
l'arrivée ça était parti bien ça a été
particulier puisque comme je leur ai dit
au départ de la dernière étape
elle l'avait fait savoir les acteurs que
je me fais des classes et moi nous
connaissons ensemble et puis comme il y
avait lui a neg avait chuté dans la
descente du mono'i ce qui était blessé
de l'hôtel jusqu'à la tête
il avait chuté d'un dessin du monde où
il ya le contre-la-montre l'avant
dernière étape je lui ai promis de le
faire gagner cette dernière étape en
complicité avec vous venez à mon ami